warriors have only one judge of honor
and character and this is themselves
decisions they make and how these
decisions are carried out
is a reflection of whom they truly are
this is one of the seven virtues of
bushido known as mayo which also means
honor not only is the word honor tossed
around a lot throughout ghost of
tsushima but it's also a driving plot
point for how jin and everyone in ghost
of tsushima acts and how it affects
their character
and that's what i want to discuss for
today i want to talk about the story of
the mongol invasion on the tsushima
island and as a result what it did to
jin and everyone around him
as always spoilers ahead as we'll be
discussing the main story for the game
and also we're going to be discussing
this in roughly the order that the game
makes us played in but i will be
referencing events that happen later in
the story
to solidify actions that take place in
earlier parts of the story
so relax for a bit and let's get into
the story of ghost of tsushima
as a samurai you fight to protect your
people and defeat anyone who opposes you
and you do so with honor
jin and his fellow samurai on top of the
hill on their horses no they won't be
coming back from this but as a samurai
you learn to control your emotions and
not to fear death
as lord shimra states tradition courage
honor
there would make us afterward lord
harunobo adachi
goes to confront the mongol leader in a
honorable one-on-one fight against the
leaders of each group
this is when we get introduced to the
main antagonist of the game kotun khan
grandson of genghis khan and cousin of
kublai khan
and you can tell kotoon doesn't care for
honor as he lights lord adachi ablaze in
front of his whole army and the samurai
and the hill watching him this then
starts the attack on komodo beach
a very devastating fight and one of the
many fights that are going to be
occurring throughout the game as you
storm you are suddenly hit with arrows
from ahuacha and are forced to take the
fight on foot
after pushing forward enough you are
then hit with more arrows and artillery
and it's at this time that kotoon khan
comes from on to the battlefield to
capture lord shimra
kotun while brutal he is a smart man he
has studied the samurai code
japanese politics and their way of life
but while you were sharpening
your sword do you know how i prepared
for today
i learned i know your language
your traditions your beliefs
which villages to tame and
wish to burn he uses this knowledge to
exploit his foes for his own gain
eventually jyn will regain consciousness
saved by a mysterious woman a woman we
know
as yuna i plan to do a whole video
covering yuna and her backstory as well
as the others we meet throughout the
island
norio ishikawa lady masako among the
others so stay tuned for those videos in
the future
either way though jyn then discovers who
saved him and he realizes he's dealing
with a thief
very opposite in terms of the code they
have very opposite of a samurai
yuna then states she has a reason for
saving jin from the battlefield other
than just being nice
once again this will be talked about
more in an in-depth future dedicated
video after sneaking through the armed
soldiers you eventually find your sword
of clan sakai
this one one of the first of many
flashbacks come into play and since
we're at this point i thought it would
be a good time to put together a
timeline of how jin even got to this
beach
in the first place so we get a good
chunk of info on jin actually from
yuriko the house servant to clan sakai
who we meet later in the second act of
the game
jyn's mom had died at an early age in
his life and jin wanted to believe his
mother's passing was actually a lie and
not real so he ran into the forest for
three days and did not return home
thankfully jin's father lord kazumasu
sakai eventually found him and jin was
almost considered dead
eventually kazumasa would then die in
battle in which jin watched
jin constantly beats himself up for this
encounter as he regrets not having the
strength to help his father when he
needed him the most
and that if he helped him he would still
be alive following his death a funeral
was held in which the other clan showed
up to mourn the death of jinn's
father lord shimmer then passes down the
family's sakai blade and says that
tomorrow he will train jinn as his ward
while training lord shimura tells him to
state the virtues they follow and that
as a samurai you must set an example for
the people by remaining true to the code
and yourself which is loyalty to our
lord control over our emotions
and honor to fight bravely and uphold
the legacy of the clan
but jinn also states that his version of
honor is also protecting people
especially the ones who cannot fight for
themselves this then leads to another
flashback of the two looking for a bear
an assassin tries to sneak up behind
lord shimra in an attempt to attack him
this teaches jin that only
cowards strike from the shadows and to
fight with the enemy head on with
courage and respect
and to either kill them or die with
honor courage respect
patience honor integrity loyalty
these are the virtues all this turns
jinn into what we have
now jyn then escapes with yuna grabs a
horse and heads back to ocasso canada to
get lord shimura back
he is then met with kotu and khan who
defeats jin and throws him off the
bridge
once awoken he is then taken to the
golden temple one of the many safe
havens not under mongol control
breaking into the castle isn't that easy
jin needs allies and he plans to recruit
lady masako sensei ishikawa and yun's
brother taka to help her take
the castle when you arrive at ishikawa's
dojo it had been torn apart
as we find later from sensei ishikawa it
was that his student tomoy who ended up
leaving
and betraying him jin must help ishikawa
track toma way down so she can answer
for her crimes
for lady masako her estate is just as
bad as a condition as the previous dojo
we just mentioned apparently during the
invasion of the mongols someone decided
to kill off the remaining members of the
family everyone died except lady masako
so she is now the lone survivor of clan
adachi
so then jin is tasked with helping lady
masako find the killer of her family
as for yuna her brother taka is a master
blacksmith when he was captured so you
have to search around and find him
this is where jin also first kills
someone from behind and as we know from
the hunting flashback you're supposed to
fight the enemy head-on
and look them in the eyes as you take
their light this is one of the many
situations where jyn has
no choice and has to do what is
necessary versus what the part of the
code is in order to survive
in all of these missions your intended
goal is not reached furuna getting taka
is part of the main quest so this will
happen naturally but for sensei ishikawa
and lady masako
quests can be done and stopped right
there they will continue to fight with
you no matter how far you progress
so it's entirely up to the player
eventually jin meets yuna at a home in
southern asimo where a new ally
enters the sake dealing merchant kenji
every mission with kenji is always so
bizarre so it's a nice
break from more of the serious stuff the
game has to offer
now kenji has known yuna and taka for a
long time in his life he used to make
them taste test his sake and then use
them to sell it to others but after
riding in the cart you make it to
azumabe
and once you finish sneaking around and
tailing a few guards you end up finding
taka who has been beaten and broods by
the mongols and almost killed if you
hadn't stepped in
even with these allies it is still not
enough so jin must recruit the straw hat
ronin a fearsome group of individuals
who will dedicate their life to the bow
and blade
also having taka make him a tool to
climb the walls of castle canada
the ronin are near kishi grasslands and
you become introduced to one of them
when you are saved when attacked by a
mongol this specific ronin is
actually an old friend of jinns ryuzo
they're good friends
with a slightly troubled past but that's
a story for another time
the issue is that the straw hats are
dying there's not enough food for the
group to survive the week so to
hopefully get ryuzo and the straw hats
on your side jin helps them retrieve
food by stealing it from a nearby fort
forth o'hira once jyn clears out the
fort he realizes there isn't any food as
this is a depot it is a temporary
holding spot and the plan is to take it
all
offshore possibly to prevent what is
happening now taking back the food
thankfully the boats are still at the
depots up by creating a major
distraction jyn and ryuzo can move in
but for the second time
ryuzo comes back empty-handed to his men
as the mongols have burned the boat and
the food was gone
luckily though on the boat there was a
map with some destinations that could
lead to some supply lines and food but
it's not guaranteed
reusa then accepts your proposal of
joining the group to help break out lord
shimra but you can tell he's isn't
exactly happy as his men
are his top priority this prioritization
ryuzo has
is what's going to cause some unsavory
problems in the future after helping the
ronin jinn then goes to kamatsu forge to
find taka and it becomes attacked by the
mongol forces since komatsu's forge is a
very popular area within the izuhara
section of the island and is the biggest
town village for
blacksmith so cutting the saw from the
samurai and taking it as their own is
very key to winning this battle
jyn also needs the forge as he needs a
tool to climb the wall which can be made
at the forge while taka and the
residents of kamatsu stay hidden jin
must protect the forge from the mongol
invaders in doing so rewards him with
the kagi nawa allowing him to swing
around gaps and reach higher places
over at castle canada kotun has reports
of your ghostly actions and lord shimmer
refuses to believe that this is true
as he says lord sakai would never resort
to such tactics
it's also here that we discover a small
part of kotun's plan which is to gather
more men from the samurai and the people
of tsushima
so we can have enough of an army to
overthrow the shogun on the mainland
while this isn't exactly part of his
entire plan there's a lot more
to him than that once again covered in a
future dedicated video while getting the
kaginawa from taka ryuza then interrupts
the conversation and states that his men
have been kidnapped at a nearby fort
but something's off as he reports the
sounds of singing amongst his men not
exactly something captives would be
doing
on the road to the fort we delve more
into riusa's backstory and why he seemed
so judgmental of jinn from the very
beginning and it was because when they
were younger
there was a tournament being held by
lord nago and ryuzo invited all the
commanders of the clan to watch his
sparring match with jin
but the people on the island only wanted
to see jin as he was the jito's nephew
and not some average warrior with no
clan name you were born lord sakai that
tournament was my one
chance to gain attention to enter the
service of the lord
become a samurai after you arrive where
the leftover straw hats are waiting
one of them states that some of the men
have left so morale is decreasing
rapidly once you make it to fort yatate
and request you the straw hats you
signal ryuzo and take the fight to the
mongols
according to ryuzo they were singing
because the mongols were actually
feeding the straw hats and some very
unique food as well
they haven't eaten anything for days so
that was definitely worth celebrating
with all the preparations made it is
time to take the fight to castle canada
but ryuzo hasn't arrived yet there is no
time so jin will have to do it without
him sneaking through the castle using
stealth and the new kaginawa jinn goes
deeper into the castle
and finds ryuzo jin has a bounty on his
head put on by kotun
khan and ryuzo is desperate to save his
men so he has to do what he can to
survive even if it has to kill his old
friend even after defeating ryuzo jin
still offers ryozo a second chance to
help him but he refuses ryozo is now
considered a traitor and there is no
coming back from this anymore
jin goes to the top of the castle to
rescue lord shimra and retakes the
castle
from the mongol invaders but kotoon
wasn't there as he went north to attack
toyotama
the neighboring territory but things are
looking better as lord shimra is alive
and not captured anymore so morale is
boosting
except that ryuzo is still working with
kotun to get food but has to earn it by
burning innocent villagers at a castle
while lord shimra scolds shin for acting
without honor and not following the code
and becoming the ghost that he will
eventually turn into
lord shimra seems to be stuck in his old
ways as he still has a distaste for
yarikawa thanks to the rebellion years
before
and comments about it to yoona people
have no love for me
i know i grew up there
is that where you learn to steal this
shows how stubborn lord shimmer is about
his ideals and the perception of people
and once again
this ideology that he has will cause
some unsavory problems in the future
right away at the start of act 2 jin
must take back castle shimra but to do
so he needs even more support
than before so he's gonna be recruiting
the peasants of old yarikawa and the
shogun in japan
we get to meet an unexpected ally at
this point a warrior monk from cedar
temple named norio he has an incredible
backstory that we will also be covering
in a future dedicated video
but from where he came from he said that
he was ambushed and taken captive by the
mongols like the previous members of the
group
norio also has side quests you can
choose to do but it's entirely up to you
he will still fight for you regardless
so for act 2 there are three main
objectives claiming the armor of clan
sakai
recruiting the peasants of yarikawa and
then getting a message to the shogun
about the attack
to get the message to the shogun jin
travels to umugi cove to meet a drunken
man named goro he's an expert on the sea
and the only one who's going to be able
to get the message across
in time so he's the only option to do
this jin meets with lord shimura and
goro to devise a plan
the plan is that they need to draw
attention to a fort near the coast so
that the naval guards and ships within
the fort are distracted by jin
and shimra allowing guru to sail freely
to japan
almost immediately noise has been made
jin and shimra have the ford's whole
attention running through and clearing
as many people as they can
as they get caught by a huacha a device
capable of shooting dozens of arrows
within seconds jin then overtakes the
huacha but realizes they do not succeed
in the plan and goro was found jin takes
matters into his own hands and uses it
to defend guru which shimura was
hesitant about at first since it's a
weapon of the enemy and that's not the
samurai way
but quickly realizes there is no other
option and getting the message to the
shogun is what matters
because of its powerful attacks and
speed the huacha is easily able to
defeat the mongol fleet
and garo is on his way to japan which
shimura reveals that not only did the
note request the shogun's help but to
also formally adopt jinn as his son
a huge moment for both of them as
they've been together since the
beginning ever since
jin's parents have died beginning as a
master and student and now reclaiming
the castle as father and son
for the people of yarikawa it's not
about storming a fort it's defending one
the people of yarikawa are still alive
and well even after the rebellion but
are now under attack from mongol forces
since yarikawa is surrounded you have to
sneak through an old entrance
which you make it inside you have a
meeting with ujimasu son of the old
leader of the yarikawa the one selling
in the rebellion
ujimasa does not want help but helping
in the battle against the mongols
may be enough to convince him to help
you the issue is that it's a small
amount of samurai and a larger army of
mongols
but apparently some skilled archers of
yarikawa have gone missing and
recruiting them to help
might just turn the battle in their
favor after enough searching jin finds
the archers and helps break out the
fellow archers that were captured so you
can prepare an ambush and wipe the
mongol forces with ease
now that the archers are safe and back
home it's time to defend the town
night hits and the attack has started
the mongols have an overwhelming force
full of swordsmen brutes archers and
even a couple siege weapons
after some time jyn disposes of them and
sprints to the temple to defeat general
tugame
once defeated from a game mechanic
standpoint you get the ghost dance but
from a story perspective your legend has
been growing across the island at a
rapid rate and everyone knows of you and
the ghostly actions you've been
performing
so when faced and go stance is activated
you are such a fearsome warrior that you
scared the mongols allowing them to be
killed instantly and any ones that were
not killed will be running away in fear
now that the mongols fear you driving
out the invaders of yarikawa as simple
as they've retreated immediately and
with your help yarikawa is safe once
again and they have offered to join you
in your fight against the khan
after defeating the mongols from
attacking yarikawa kotun meets with
ryuzo and mentions he has a plan to
eliminate jin
ryuzo has one as well but offers that he
should do it without requiring the
killing of jin but this will come into
play later but now that all the
objectives are finished the very last
thing to do is to claim the family armor
of clan sakai
jin travels to omi village where his
estate lies he then finds his old house
servant yuriko who we briefly mentioned
earlier
in an attempt to stop anyone from
getting the mementos from the clan they
hid the armor
which she will then go fetch for you
while she fetches the armor you can go
to your father's cemetery a beautiful
looking place with generations of legacy
behind it which all led to you being the
next in line with the sakai armor jin
has realized fighting the mongols is
going to require a lot more than what he
has now
another instance of him choosing what he
needs to do over what the samurai code
wants him to do
so he asks yuriko if he can procure some
poison for him to use it against the
mongol invasion
once jyn grabs the dart and blow gun
from a fort and some herbal ingredients
near the cemetery
yuriko can then make the poison darts
for you and jin will be able to use the
poison darts against the mongol invasion
you can have to play through yuriko's
tail and earn the hallucination dart
which causes enemies to turn on each
other but it's not an unnecessary item
for the story with all the preparations
made it's time to take the fight to the
mongols and co-tune once again to take
over the castle and rid the mongols of
even more territory but before that
happens jyn receives word that ryuzo is
going to use the straw hats to flank the
army
so you must take care of him at first
before you proceed with the frontal
assault
jyn requests eunice help but said she's
leaving in the morning and already holed
up her end of the deal
jin accepts and continues alone upon
reaching the fort you find taka is there
taka left yuno when she wasn't paying
attention so that he can help
he proposes an idea of creating a
distraction to sneak into the fort
unnoticed which it works originally as
you sneak into the fort until ryuzo
finds you and you're knocked unconscious
by a straw hat
and taken captive taka notices that jin
took too long to finish up in the fort
and wanted to check on him to make sure
everything was okay
and go into plan but ended up getting
caught as well with the two of them held
captive jin is then given the choice of
surrender by kotun khan as he arrives
he refuses so he unravels taka's binds
and says to kill
jin and he'll be set free taka continues
to play nice then swings at the khan
which the khan dodges then proceeds to
kill taka in front of jin
leaving his headless corpse in front of
jin to look at hoping that he will think
to himself and possibly ponder
if surrendering could have saved taka
and his friends once jin has an
opportunity he breaks free and causes
havoc
on the straw hats throughout the fort
when jin gets to a gate he finds that
yuna was here when she realized that
taka
wasn't here with him she went to go see
him she then finds out about taka's
death and is overcome with all sorts of
emotion and takes to the fight with the
straw hats along with you remaining in
the fort
once that's over jin helps yuna bury
taka now that the flanking threat is
over
it's time to do a frontal assault on the
castle lord shimra the shogun and all of
jin's allies he's accumulated throughout
his journey
fight alongside him together to retake
castle shimra after waves of enemies you
make it through multiple gates of the
castle defeating every swordsman and
archer in sight
you make it to another gate in which you
climb atop to scout the enemy ahead
and use this opportunity to make use of
the poison killing the nearby guards
and slicing the mongol's head clean off
with one strike but not only is jin
striking from behind he's also using
poison to kill his enemies
not what a samurai should do so once
again lord shimro will scold him once
more
jin clears even more of the fort using a
huacha this time to ease through the
process and then comes to the bridge
the mongols retreat to draw the
samurai's attention and launch horses
with explosives in the carriages to
simultaneously blow up the bridge and
the samurai forces
jit is extremely upset by this and goes
back to his honor code of honor which is
to protect people and lord shimra is
just sending people to their deaths even
if it's honorable
it's not right lord shima then suggests
that they repair the bridge and attack a
dawn once it's finished but jin suggests
that he sneaks into the fort and uses
poison on the enemy
there is a large disagreement between
the two one wants to win the war or die
with honor the other wants to do what is
necessary to win and give the people
hope for a better future ana
died on the beach the khan deserves to
suffer
you were ruled by your emotion
i sacrificed everything i knew to save
our people i gave them hope
you did nothing with that jyn leaves and
once again decides to go against the
code he's grown up with and to do what
he can to save his people
as nightfall comes you gear up with new
armor that taka made for you before he
passed
with that and the kaginawa jyn sneaks
along the bridge and into the mongol
side of the fort
the plan is to sneak around to where the
milk is being held and poison it so that
everyone who drinks will die
allowing safe passage to the khan after
sneaking through and making sure not to
draw any attention jinn poisons the milk
and watching everything unfold as an
army of mongols who are once standing
tall are now coughing up their own blood
and dying in front of him after
everybody has died jin makes his way to
the main keep assuming he will meet
kotun but instead he finds ryuzo ryuza
this time wants to not kill jin but it's
too far
rizo has already betrayed jin's trust
and is unable to make up for it so a
duel ensues
after defeating ryuzo jin grants him a
honorable warrior's death and leaves him
there
as he walks out lord shimmer arrives
with his band of samurai and confronts
jin on his actions
lord shimmer says the shogun will want
to head for these crimes that he's
committed and that he can blame the act
of terror on yunna all he has to do is
renounce the name of the ghost
jyn refuses as he knows what he did was
right and what he had to do
for this he was thrown in jail to await
punishment for his actions
and the document that is presumed to
have the official announcement of jin's
adoption to lord shimra
is then burned away with nothing but ash
remaining it's unclear how long he was
put in jail but after some time a
familiar face comes by to lure the guard
away from his post
and have jin escape lord asked me to
deliver sake
a reward for helping retake his home
receives word from kenji that yuna and
all of his other allies are waiting for
him and figuring out a way to stop the
khan so jin sneaks through the samurai
guards up until the gate when he's
caught and then shot at by arrows for
escaping
your horse takes a few shots and you can
get just far enough but not your full
destination and it will succumb to its
wounds and die in front of you
and with that we come to the final act
act three at the start of act 3
jyn has no weapons or armor just
clothing jyn is tasked with going to the
sacred tree to find yuna and take the
fight to the khan once again
once jin gets the tree he notices that
she isn't there
then an arrow hits him the mongols took
after jin and started using poison
luckily before jin dies yuna comes to
the rescue again
and saves him once you collect all your
gear you head out in search of a base
camp which is jokaku's pagoda
to get there you kill the guards by the
fishing hut and then launch a cannon
that alerts the guards at the temple and
lure them into a barrel and eliminate
them all at once
now that there is less guards going into
the temple should be a whole lot easier
and now that the base has been
established all there is left to do is
reunite the allies and kill kotoon khan
to do so you need to free a nearby fort
from mongol control
and some of yoona's friends might be
able to help you out with that once jin
goes inside and starts with the first
area he moves to area after area of the
fort stopping anyone who opposes him
and then the door bus open and it's all
of your allies and friends ready to back
you up once more all that's left is the
khan but you can't go through the front
gate without a plan
and jin knows this the khan has ended up
being stationed at port izumi so there
is a lighthouse that is nearby which can
be used to scout out the area for a plan
on how to proceed
the khan is going to take supplies in
the barrels of poison to the mainland
and use it against the shogun and his
army in light of this news jin then
travels to kashil shimra even though he
is still wanted
sneaks into the castle to notify lord
shimra via a note on what the khan is
planning to do in hopes of him joining
with his army
while infiltrating the castle you find
out that the shogun has orders for lord
shimra which is mentioned at the end of
the game but it's a foreshadowing of
what's to come
once you leave you go back to the pagoda
to talk about the plan to your allies
and then afterwards the final battle
will commence
you rush through killing enemy remaining
mongol forces left and pushed through to
the khan
the archers have opted to use poison now
thanks to jin's actions at casual shimra
and halfway through the engagement one
of the gates busts open and it's lord
shimra and his shogun samurai army
at the gate ready to attack while they
distract the enemy you make it to the
manor where the khan is hiding and you
start the final one-on-one battle
between jin and kotoon khan
jin manages to wound the khan greatly
and he uses this opportunity to use more
cheap tactics and poison gin and run to
the boat to escape
you end up catching up to him before he
takes off and you fight off waves of
enemies on top of kotoon in an attempt
to end his life
jin manages to greatly wound kotun and
kotun will then say
his death does not matter as he will be
remembered but jin assures him that
that's wrong and he will be remembered
not him once you kill kotoon the mongol
threat is no more or at least not as
huge as it was
there are still mongols on the island
but not in working order as their leader
has been slain
after the battle jyn then talks to yuna
and then yuna mentions that
jin has a letter from lord shimra and
meets him at the original training spot
he mentions how if they work together
they can finish off the rest of the
forces but lord shimra has other plans
as well as the shogun clan sakai is no
longer a clan and their territory is no
longer theirs whoever decides to take it
be it a new or old clan will claim the
spot
jin is also no longer considered a
samurai anymore of course going against
the code
you then ride with lord shimra for the
very last time and then when you
eventually make it to your father's
cemetery it is then discovered that the
shogun declares jin
a traitor and that the price of it is
his head to be taken by lord shimra as
lord jimar as punishment you write down
the very last words of clan sakai in
form of haiku
and then dual lord shimra the game at
this point presents you with two options
kill lord shimra or spare him virgin
either option is really not a good
option
if he kills him he shows that he still
has honor but he has to kill his uncle
in front of him
but if he spares him his uncle gets to
live but shows that honor is no longer a
part of him
even for his family regardless of the
option you choose it is up to the player
the only difference is that killing lord
shimra gives you the ghost armor in
white and while sparing him will give it
to you
in red the house is also the still the
same with all the items inside that you
can look around in
except the locations are slightly
different killing him gives you the
broken down house near mamoushi
grassland and then sparing him gives you
the broken down house near omi village
other than that there is really no
difference the ghost is still alive and
well and will be haunted by the shogun
for the rest of his days for not being
dealt with
if that happens in a future dlc remains
to be seen
and that is the story of ghost of
tsushima and i want to thank you guys
for joining me on this very long ride
this was a fantastic game and very
unique in many ways
like i said in the beginning i have
plans to make videos on other characters
like cartoon lord shimra yuna as well as
many other characters as they have all
of their different reasons for joining
jin on the battle
and their own personal troubles that jin
can help them with which i believe need
their own dedicated video to delve into
with that i want to thank you guys for
coming to the video let me know how you
guys thought about ghost of tsushima
down in the comments below like i said
it's been a fantastic ride playing this
game one of the best games i've played
in a very long time
and a really good end to the ps4 era and
hopefully if it comes to the ps5 it'll
look
even better yeah as well if you have any
other questions or any other types of
videos you want me to make in terms of
ghost of tsushima with some of the
characters mentioned
as well just leave them in the comments
below but with that like to be if you do
enjoy subscriber for new guys
take care and goodbye
[Music]
you